you know look trump's going to get way
nastier and uglier over the next 30 days
like it's becoming
very apparent he is out the door he's
given all these sort of is he going to
go to an
inauguration you think he'll show up he
is way too shallow
petty do you think he'll show up do you
think he'll show up
do you think he'll show up sore loser
bro you don't think he'll you think
he'll show up he'll show up at his rally
that day you think he'll show up yeah
he'll do it so let me get this straight
you think he'll show up none of you guys
think he's going to show up today
no i do time out i'm taking that back he
will show up i mean come on
the guy is a true american he has
respect for protocol in this country
he realizes how much you want to bet
well
125. 125 bucks he doesn't let me know
let me ask the other check on it
let
let me ask the other question here's the
other question for you is there even
going to be an inauguration
because if you can't it's all about
social distance how weird of an
inauguration is that if you have to sit
six feet apart so that means
trumps are gonna sit six feet apart from
bidens they're gonna from obama's are
gonna sit six feet apart from clinton's
that inauguration is not gonna be a half
a million people showing up
so is it even gonna be an inauguration
is it even gonna be the same one or will
it be a
zoom inauguration will it be a tv
inauguration it may not be
an inauguration that you're thinking
it'll be just like one of his rallies
where 15 people show up and cause social
justice why if it's that and he doesn't
show up i don't think it's a big deal
i think trump shows up maskless possibly
shirtless he don't give [ __ ] man no no
he's not gonna show up shirtless but
but what i'm trying to say to you is it
i think it'll have a lot to do with
as these cases are going up and
everybody's panicking about cases i got
a call yesterday from a friend of mine
who his son works at the icu in
baltimore okay
jordan shout out to jordan and shout out
to
mehran and he called me says listen i
just want you to know my son told me
that the icu is so packed right now with
people with cases that's non-stop
he just dropped me a nice message saying
just don't be a
uh uh uh what's the word he uses he says
don't be a denier said maverick or
something like no no not the denier
he said don't be a maverick don't be
this just keep this part of mind that my
son works in icu and by the way this is
a pretty conservative guy so he's not
coming from a place of
you know poli there is no politics in
his comments right
but uh if the cases are going up and
it's real
there is no inauguration because it
shows
that his messaging that he's going to
come out and he's going to say
i'm the more responsible guy on how to
handle covet you can't have an
inauguration the inauguration is out the
window because
you're shown a lack of responsibility if
you are gonna have an inauguration
so if there is not one and he doesn't
show up i don't think it's a big deal i
think they could do it without the
public
right i mean keep them like put your
hand on the bible do the thing on tv but
you also made a really good point that
not being an inauguration because trump
could still win then there wouldn't be
an inauguration
there would actually still be an
inauguration even if he wins because
when you get when you win again you get
inaugurated again
that's just how it works um but
again i don't think that's happening i
think biden will have a more subdued
inauguration a little social distance
not not as crazy i don't think biden is
there for like the look at my crowds
look how big
he's just like look bro let's you know i
got a bad ankle let's just keep this
thing moving let's
that's what i'm saying what i'm trying
to say is i don't even i think this is
going to be a very weird but you have
but i don't think it's going to be a
zoom
type of inauguration ready you have to
be ready for anything this year this is
a very weird year so
if you're going to be surprised by
inauguration not being the traditional
one you are naive
this is a very weird year he may just
come out and do something basic and they
leave and boom
so now the question becomes do i think
on the same exact day trump will hold a
rally
here's what i think let me i'll give you
my opinion number one i think he's
capable of doing that number two i think
it's not the right thing to do
okay i think he's capable of doing that
i don't think it's the right thing to do
uh will he do it i think there's a 70
chance that he would do something like
that
okay his own rally i don't think it's a
good idea to do that i i don't think
it's a good idea for you to do that look
you know a voter fraud did it happen 100
it happened it happens every single time
was there more this time than the other
100 i fully believe it because there was
one thing different about this ballot
than the other ones which
is what a bunch of mailing ballots and
and you're you're poised
to do voter fraud the other day i'm
talking to a guy who works for
uh uh one of the guys that was involved
politically in jfk's candidate
uh jfk is a campaign where they did the
whole voting stuff and you know where
the guy said what the daily said what
folks make sure you go vote and vote
often you know you
you know maybe keep voting don't just
you understand what was their mantra
yeah that was their mantra
and often right okay so yes it happened
it happened
guess what your strategy sucked there's
beats you
period that's all there is to it you
lost to a better strategy
and four years ago guess what hillary
clinton your strategy
sucked you lost his was better and you
need to go home
and she went home and for the rest of
her career she's talked about what
she threw russia at him she played games
she did all that other stuff
is trump gonna do to biden what hillary
did to trump
100 if you think for a second trump's
going to sit around
he's going to do exactly what hillary
did to trump he's going to do exactly
what obama did to trump he's going to go
after biden he's going to go after all
those guys i don't think that's going to
stop
i just don't think it's a good idea for
him to go and hold an event on the same
day as inauguration
i i think what it does to him to the
base that he needs so
becoming a president he got 74 million
votes which is the most ever by a
sitting president that's never happened
before biden ended up getting 80 million
votes which
if you take the mail-in ballots out that
number is probably going to be a lot
lower than what it was because mail-in
ballots people send on
more ballots on both sides 74 to 80
million
what we learned is you ain't gonna
become a president without flipping the
middle
you're not so it's not about your swing
states you are not
like one of the things obama said
yesterday when he talked about defunding
the police which we'll get into here in
a minute we'll go into the
right next obama talks
purely strategically everything about
obama is strategic
there's something to be learned about
obama because what obama was
able to do he was able to get the
independence to say what
you know what i i like the way he said
that america is about
there it's not about just the
republicans and democrats and
independent americans about
latino community america's about blacks
america is about the white americans
about suburbia america is about this
america's about farmers america's about
lgbt america
this is the uh he gave that message and
independent said
you know what i'm just going to vote for
this guy i'm cool with this guy if trump
doesn't play that card oh dude you ain't
getting the vote that you need i'm just
saying
so strategically it's not a good
strategy okay and i think that plays
into his speech yesterday this 46-minute
speech this wasn't a campaign speech i
personally in all seriousness if nothing
changes regarding the voter fraud if
there is no proof or this thing doesn't
get flipped
i don't think he'll show up at the
inauguration i'll tell you why because i
don't think
he believes this is the same america
going forward
because of the result of this election
and if they got away with it once
and if they get that one more senate
seat in georgia what they're going to be
able to do in the next four years is
unbelievable
and prevent a guy from trump from even
having a
chance of winning an election i think
that's why that speech he made yesterday
once you get past your hatred of him or
anything else about him that bugs you
that's what he was talking about and if
he went to the inauguration he'd be
conceding the fact that he lost the
election in his mind
which works a little bit differently he
doesn't believe he did he had it stolen
from him
so i don't think he would show up and if
he's going to run again in 2024 i think
he would feel it's a bad precedent for
him to go
admit failure admit i lost he would ride
that wave of four years saying i never
did
that but let me let me explain this
thing to you so i'm watching the
commentary right and people are saying
you're you're this and i'm trump's gonna
do this and you don't understand america
is with trump and america's with this
i don't i don't disagree that america's
not with trump i don't disagree that
america's not with trump
i also don't disagree that america is
also with biden okay
you got 80 million you got 74 million
i'm very comfortable knowing that
america is with
a portion of americans with what with
both sides right
but this is not about that tom this
isn't about you
this isn't about you this isn't about
you and this isn't about you
this is about who you can convert you
see when there's a debate in politics to
me
if i walk away and you walk away
and you walk away no one's mind's been
changed a little bit by one percent it
was a waste of a meeting
but if you walk away and adam walks away
and i walk away and i say you know what
adam had a point about the
you know when he talked about biting and
he comes out and
you know and and you know china tariffs
are not really he's holding it in okay i
mean that that's a good point in the
you know cabinet he chose elizabeth
warren's not in it sanders not in it aoc
is not in it ilanomar's not in it
so maybe he is democratic and left maybe
he's not far left maybe it's not that
bad
and he could walk away and say you know
what maybe maybe trump's policies
are good for business and maybe it
benefits me the point i'm trying to make
it's not about your base it's about
converting
a part of the base that's not your base
you got to win
them over how do you win them over to
win them over
you have to come across united you
cannot come across as us against the
world
it doesn't work that way not about
presidential it could work in mayor
it could work in senate it could work in
house it could work in
it could work in governor it cannot work
with presidency
you got to win the middle community that
says you seem reasonable enough that
you're going to be fair with me and them
because they don't like like for example
you know the whole the the last debate
trump did with biden
look look at trump's first debate with
biden look at trump's last debate with
biden
night and day he was i mean trump
crushed it on the
second one yeah first first one first
one was
trump was a disaster why did america
like the second one
he was yeah he was composed he was
measured
see that was kind of like you know what
this is the guy i want to see
and then when he got covered he said
look this thing is real i have to tell
you it's real i've had it it's not
something and you know
people are like oh wow you know this
guy's got the side but then he went back
to
let me tell you you don't convert it's
about a conversion game it's not just
your base
i may be wrong guys i'm just a business
guy but i think there's a little bit of
strategy there that he's going to do
better
one quick go ahead just one quick
remodel i think trump believes he did
that
he won the hispanic vote he dominated
that latino vote
what do you mean well i mean look
tremendous progress
he did but he did very well we don't
know he went from 15
he did very well with the blind still
lost he did very well that's a dream
what are you talking about but he didn't
win
of course it's it's winning it's 33
percent growth in a community voting for
you
and nobody ever thought they said this
guy's not going to win but he didn't get
more than 50 percent yeah but he did
what pat was referencing
is he flipped enough people into the
middle that generally
so for example house pelosi lost a few
seats her own side is saying i'm not
going to vote for it to be the house of
the secretary
you know what do you call speaker of the
house why dude
you're not flipping me i'm not staying
with you it's about
converting a few he took a latino from
15 to
20. and he his african-american vote is
the highest for republicans
in 12 percent now that's massive i know
it went that's
three times mccain three times mccain
he's done that part but i just think he
had to now flip a little bit of the
independent and he did it
and one last thing i think if you look
at i think he's holding back information
he knows he can't say
i mean you watch him on that speech
yesterday and it's like he wants to
reveal more information
of things that he actually knows maybe
he could think he's holding back and you
know i think at this point
i do i i totally do he can't release it
all right i respect what you're saying
i don't think trump has the capability
of holding anything in i think he's just
gonna
get out there and say what he wants to
say whether you guys like it right there
he says
no pat you're wrong biden did not get
more votes than obama
it has nothing to do with winning the
middle it's impossible i disagree
i i disagree listen i want you to
understand this part
i i do think there is voter fraud
yeah people have how many times offline
have i told you there was voter fraud
how many times yes you've told it many
times every time i've said my position
doesn't change
there was voter fraud do i voter fraud
in every election i get that but but
bro biden's not an 80 million vote guy
no way
there's been a lot of people that have
been hated by the other side biden's not
an 80 million vote guy
this time around he was there is no way
in the world there's nothing
about biden that's what is he what's his
number he's a 65 million vote guys so so
you're saying that
that there was 15 million what i'm
trying to tell you is he's the base guy
he needs to get the votes at the base
the democrats that are like i hate the
other guy
but he's not an 80 million guy he's not
because 80 million means
the middle went left that's 80 million
it's he's not
he's not that guy obama is and was
obama bill clinton is and was okay
george bush believe it or not is and was
okay
reagan 100 because reagan carter was not
it was he was not popular there's
nothing about carter that was popular
carter got lucky when he became
president the timing was perfect for
carter to become president
and he became a one-term president but
but i don't believe
the 80 million votes that biden got
israel 80 million votes i don't believe
that
but even with that being said even
without all the manipulation that took
place
if barr comes out and says there's no
voter fraud
highlight that right you drop highlight
what no i'm just saying that's a major
thing
yeah if barr comes out and says as of
right now we've not found it the
attorney general
yes the attorney general that's a
pro-trump guy pro-trump the biggest
protester
i i'm giving it to you if he comes out
if one state after another state after
another state after another state by the
way even if let's just say he wins
michigan
it's still about 270 for biden he has to
flip three
four states for it to turn this is again
what i'm going to with you on this is
when when it happened and everybody said
oh this is going to go
you know this many weeks and it's going
to be you know trump's going to be able
to flip it i'm like dude we're not
talking about one state
if it was only arizona yes if it was
only georgia yes
if it was only wisconsin yes if it was
only michigan yes if it was only
pennsylvania
fine yes but we're talking about
five states look
you know you got you got to go and then
now trump yesterday or two days ago says
at a party
that he's going to come back 2024. it's
a message saying
i concede if i'm going to come back
2024. so
is there a part of it that he's certain
he was cheated out of an election
i think he was cheated out of an
election
you